by the way with that story with uh fox
news story being brilliant you saw
wallace went to cnn right on their app
and then howard stern says who gives a
[ __ ] no one's no one watches cnn's apps
anyway so what are you going on there
for uh and then uh what's it called
brian williams uh uh uh resigned he left
yes bye-bye yeah so he leaves wallace to
cnn
what do you think about what's going on
here
what did that negotiation sound like
with wallace was it kind of like well
cnn you ain't looking too good i think
it's a good time you hire a conservative
i'm a good guy to hire because i'm
pretty safe but here's what i want from
you if you give me these things i'll
come if you don't i'm not coming and
sienna needed that victory to say we got
somebody from fox you think that's the
play no i don't know because if you take
a look chris wallace he was not
expensive brian williams was very
expensive
what was fox payne chris wallace
pox
well brian williams was like at four and
a half a year and they were stuck with
him because it was this long-term
contract and then he had the you know i
was being chased by helicopters with
gunfire and everything like this and the
lies that he told about all that yeah i
think he was making more than four seven
million wallace was paying paid seven
million that does that does not wow
that's insane money telling you right
now you know seven million dollars
15 20. i mean when he was when he was
doing nightly news he was making 15
years
you know but but you're right patrick
there's a lot of shuffling going on
chris wallace right now chris wallace
also has the name mike wallace you know
he's got the lineage there so there's 10
million
chris wallace is a democrat and a lot of
fox news watchers were getting
irritated with him
just like they were shepard smith i like
i thought he was a fantastic job
there's a very very very very very
measure that he did with bill clinton
bill clinton came out of his shoes and
was leaning into his face right into his
grill yeah remember when he moderated
the debate and everybody was all over
chris wallace because he wasn't hard
enough on the democrats you could kind
of see that you know he really did and
after 18 years with fox news you
probably want to go somewhere else and
have a little bit different perspective
spin that you can put on stories and i
think it's it's not just a show it's
it's cnn digital right so it's going to
be a different type of format he
probably just needed a challenge in his
career yeah but it's just like kidding
me katie who bill o'reilly has faded
into the
uh oblivion yeah yeah
and katie but but different
circumstances he was ousted because of
sexual harassment true and nobody else
hired him you know he's gonna be front
and center at cnn be the face of their
digital
i bet they paid them 12. what do you
think brian's going to be doing next
brian williams i couldn't find cnn
digital if you i can't even google cnn
digital i don't think there's any i
don't think there's any market for brian
williams whatsoever i don't think he'll
get a job i don't think he'll get a high
level network job no way and i don't see
him being savvy enough to go the glenn
beck route or anything like that and he
doesn't have any particular views that
you buy into i never bought brian
williams in general no because he does
not have a magnetic position there's not
a magnetic position the way there always
was for rush there always was for back
there always was for hannah you know
what i'm saying they have that center
that's that the cultivar personality i
think i think you have to have enemies
to be cult-like brian williams wasn't
necessarily a guy that had too many
enemies he'll be like matt lauer just
fade away in the hamptons the warning
menu discovery deal means for cnn and
jeff sucker what am i looking at cnn's
about to be acquired by warner media and
their ratings are obviously tanking so
you have to wonder between chris wallace
chris cuomo etc what are they trying to
do are they trying to shake things up
they're trying to get more moderate to
bring their ratings up like they have to
do something they're a sinking jeff
zucker has no clout in the deal have you
noticed that
going through it he's got no position
coming out of the deal discovery's going
to run the thing it's a good point you
make tyler there so so what what are you
saying are you saying um
are you saying like they have to become
moderate because no one wants nobody
wants to buy cnn type of business i
don't i don't think they have to become
moderate per se but they have to move
away from the far left almost
propagandist brainwashing get away from
the brian stelters and and and that kind
of stuff which is where a a chris
wallace sort of moderate can come in and
change things up i think jeff zucker
will be possibly gone after this like
you look at what they did after bringing
back jeffrey tubin yeah i mean it's they
they've just completely shot themselves
in the foot and they have to do
something
where do you get your news from what do
you watch
i don't i don't listen to anything i
watch bloomberg you watch bloomberg well
but because it's bloomberg tv it's got
like information i got you that's a
different story though yeah yeah that's
a different story
the 35 000 year type of deal you talk
about that you talk about the membership
of bloomberg no i mean i mean the
television station bloomberg tv because
it's got all the information on it i got
you i mean but you don't listen to you
don't watch or listen to anybody
is there anybody that you would say i
kind of like hearing this person's
perspective or two
i think um remember my second masters is
in journalism so i totally believe in
the the idea of fair and balanced so i
think i think brett bear is a is a good
is a good journalist i'll i'll watch him
on the evening news you know if
you know if i had to watch the evening
news but i don't i watch bloomberg asia
tom how about yourself uh in the morning
it's cnbc it's walking the street
morning bell i think and i like the way
that they put new stories in and they
kind of just give you a like a middle of
the road cover glitzy it's all that's
all entertainment i just want them
no but then i go to then i go bounce
back and forth between fox business and
cnn business and you know i'll scan you
know a bunch of uh news grabs like um
business insider i'll scan that but um i
don't have one guy that that is my go-to
you know i used to be such a news junkie
i worked in news i was an anchor for 15
years i don't watch any news i do not
sit down and watch a local newscast or a
national newscast but i can't local news
is scary yeah i consume information all
day but there's a lot
myself to get a balance and you know
what
cnn is unwatchable but cnn business is
is a very tolerable site to read i have
no problem reading cnn business
i like reading the new york post you
know i like the daily mail sometimes but
you always get bought you get sucked
into the agenda that they all have and
they all have some sort of agenda yeah
so i just tell everybody just to you
know
don't go deep on watching news i mean it
will ruin your life the financial times
is becoming woke i mean it's really
difficult right now to to not it's
really difficult to find just
unvarnished information
that's not in some way tainted by the
editorial team you can't even
i've got friends who work inside the
wall street journal who work inside the
financial times well here's one great
example pat did you hear about this
story so sunday night football michelle
tafoya is the sideline reporter right so
she hasn't been on the games for the
last three or four weeks yep i saw that
okay so now they just announced that
she's not coming back this is going to
be her last year and nbc said that she
wasn't working the previous few weeks
because it was a bye week for her which
makes zero sense all right why would you
have your star sideline reporter take a
week off you know when the nfl season
only goes 17 games so what happened
about a month ago is she was on the view
and she sat in the conservative chair
okay so for one day she was on the view
and she said on the view that day that
she thought covid was more like flu
right she downplayed the significance of
covet and since then she's been
whitewashed she's been banished she
hasn't been on the sidelines and now
she's done and pretty much that's why
people are saying it's happening she
will have a job within 30 days if she
wanted to michelle tafoya is a beast
she's not going to have a hard time
finding a job she's smart and she's
multi-sport and she doesn't need the
producer in her ear she reads the games
really well yeah yeah she's not gonna
have look look if she wants to look how
quickly she'll land the job michelle if
you're listening or if anybody knows
michelle
reach out to valuetainment
we would actually offer a job too
because she's a monster exactly i
actually love the way she uh
her salaries are earning if only we had
someone on staff that was already
looking for something okay check this
out so
uh uh what her salary is 1.96 million no
net worth is 1.96 her salary is 27 000 a
month that's what her salary is and i'm
serious it's what's showing right now 27
000 a month
abtc.ng so someone's going to pick her
up so she gets six grand a game here's
uh 200 000 a year is two hundred
thousand dollars here's what their
salary is remember espn doesn't pay as
well as people think they do right right
people think espn pays very well
nfl refs make more than that they make
way more than that
and and michelle is
got a lot of clout she's got a lot of
credibility yeah she's been around a
long time she's she's like 57 you hit
news like how michael she's awesome so
she's she hasn't taken anything yet
she's multi-sport she's covered in mba
that's what you're saying on the floor
yeah in terms of changing the calling
campaign oh she also slammed nbc's
michelle okay let me pull this one up
because you just brought it up
long time nbc sports island reporter
michelle tiforce changing roles after
criticizing colin kaepernick's netflix
series for liking the nfl to slavery
during november
episode of the view uh and yeah i
remember this uh back and forth with
what she said no one uh pressures them
so this was again on the view no one
pressures them she told view co-host
sunny hostin huston on november third
episode prompting criticism on social
media they're not forced to go into the
nfl tafoyo who has uh been on the nfl
sidelines et cetera center and loving
whatever yeah i mean if you haven't seen
it you got to watch it she's a beast she
stood her ground so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]